eran balanan vous avez qualifié vous de
provocation le texte qui était sorti du
Sénat oui parce que sous sous la volonté
de de de de plus de fermeté on fait des
choses inefficaces et et je pense qu'un
texte de cet enjeu avec les sujets
migratoires qui sont des sujets
importants qui sont des sujets de
société pour notre pays qui sont des
sujets économiques et qui sont des
sujets aussi de justice et et de d'un
certain nombre de nos valeur d'accueil
dans ce pays je pense qu' il faut pas
être dans l'idée de faire des textes
plus répressis ou plus
gauche droite il faut faire des tests
des textes qui sont justes humanistes et
efficaces et le texte quoi qu'en dise
madame joura le texte initial avait un
certain équilibre le le texte du Sénat a
voulu durcir tout un tas de de sujets il
y a des sujets d'ailleurs sur lesquels
le le les parlementaires du de
l'Assemblée ont préféré garder des
choses et puis d'autres où on a supprimé
donc c'est c'est le jeu parlementaire je
je suis désolé c'est aussi normal que la
représentation nationale s'exprime sur
un texte qui est quand même un texte du
ENF un texte important pour les pour les
députés en quoi c'était une provocation
parce que c'est fort c'était une
provocation parce que parce que on
voyait bien qu'il y avait la la la
volonté de pousser le curseur très très
loin bon c'est c'est chacun était dans
son rôle et il est passé au Sénat chez
nous en commission il est passé très
largement 34 voix contre 16 en
commission à 2h40 du matin vendredi donc
les les commissaires aux lois étaient
présents étaient mobilisés et le texte
est passé maintenant on va continuer le
travail et on continuera après le
travail avec les sénateurs de toute
façon je avant de parler de quota avant
de parler de politique migratoire je je
pense qu'il y a un sujet qu'il faut
aborder et c'est le sujet que que que
visiblement la droite sénatoriale et la
droite la droite à l'Assemblée ne veut
pas voir c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui dans
notre pays travaillent cotisent payent
leurs impôts et sont dans des situations
irrégulières alors attention ils sont
dans des situations irrégulières euh
très peu parce qu'ils ont fraudé hein
euh souvent c'est parce que problèmes
administratif euh parfois euh comment
dire euh je je il y a une erreur de de
papier parce qu'ils ont pas fait ce
qu'il fallait parfois une erreur de
l'administration aussi et on a beaucoup
de personnes dans notre pays qui
participent à la production nationale
qui participe à la création de valeur
dans notre pays et qui peuvent pas
s'intégrer vous pouvez pas vous intégrer
sérieusement quand vous travaillez la
journée et que euh la soirée et et le
matin vous pouvez pas vous occuper de
vos enfants les amener à l'école parce
que vous avez peur de de d'être contrôlé
ce n'est pas possible donc il faut aussi
gérer ce sujet alors c'est l'article 4
bis et et moi c'est là-dessus que je
pense que justement ration voilà et
c'est là que nous avons une cohérence
c'est-à-dire la cohérence de bien
accueillir les gens que nous pouvons
accueillir et après je vous rejoins
madame Jourda on ne pourra pas
accueillir tout le monde effectivement
mais attention tout à l'heure juste
avant on parlait
des changements climatiques on le sait
aujourd'hui on va avoir des flux
migratoires nouveaux il va falloir il va
falloir anticiper tout ça et je pense
que parler de quota parler de politique
chiffré tout ça tout ça oui il faudra
peut-être y réfléchir il faudra même
sûrement y réfléchir sans parler de
quotas à mon avis parce qu'on ne peut
pas mettre des quotas mais on peut avoir
des des orientations mais par contre
traitons gérons ces gens qui sont en
France qui et qui ont la dans leur
immense majorité l'envie de s'intégrer
au pays
non mais je je y a ça a été rappelé je
trouve très bien que ça soit rappelé
c'est que la question de l'asile la
question du regroupement familial c'est
conventionnel c'est on ne pourra on ne
pourra pas on pourra pas y
toucher la question des des étudiants je
rappelle que la France accueille
beaucoup d'étudiants que c'est une vraie
force pour notre
pays on peut réfléchir à à des nombres
effectivement qui permettent à nos à nos
universités de l'encaisser c'est c'est
c'est tout tout à fait logique mais ne
parlons pas de de ne faisons pas de
politique du chiffre faisons une
politique d'ambition pour le pays et
c'est ça la la différence peut-être
entre avoir des objectifs chiffrés et
puis la notion de quota très rigide qui
qui qui est très compliqué à mettre en
place d'ailleurs tous les pays qui ont
des des quotas ne respectent pas leurs
quotas donc inutile de de se cacher
derrière ces mots faisons des choses
efficaces mais non mais enfin c'est pas
du tout ça et en plus vous vous faites
vous faites à mon avis une erreur euh
mettre ça à la main du préfet euh c'est
euh voilà on le sait suivant les
départements ce n'est pas la même chose
alors que justement nous sommes la
représentation nationale et nous devons
fixer ces règles et il y a quelque chose
de très contradictoire à avoir envie
d'une politique migratoire et d'un autre
côté de la mettre aux mains du préfet
c'est à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat de décider d'un certain nombre de
règles et de de décider des règles qui
permettent de régulariser avec des
exemptions quand il y a trouble à
l'ordre public quand il y a un certain
nombre de choses et la plupart des gens
qui sont rentrés dans notre pays qui
sont aujourd'hui en situation illégale
non pas fraudé ils se sont retrouvés
dans une situation illégale suite à une
erreur de papier une erreur
administrative donc il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est paradoxale et puis
vous le savez très bien et c'est sur ce
sujet je je je ne comprends même pas
vous qui habitez le même territoire que
moi qui voyaient les mêmes personnes que
moi qui voyent les mêmes entrepreneurs
que moi qui nous disent mais sur un tas
de de de poste on a des gens ils sont là
ils ont pas leurs papi mais on les
embauche et il ils répondent
parfaitement à ce qu'on veut et ils ont
envie de s'intégrer et rég régulariser
s'il vous plaît ces personnes on l'a
tous les jours dans nos permanences et
et dans nos sur nos mails donc ne
sortons de cette hypocrisie de penser
que des gens sont là trichent et et ne
participent rien et profite du système
je crois que on a beaucoup de personnes
qui sont arrivées sur notre territoire
parfois parce qu'ils étaient étudiants
parfois par un visa de travail un
premier visa de travail et qui euh ont
envie de rester dans notre pays ont
envie de s'intégré et il y a dans ce
texte aussi et parce que c'est des
sujets sur auquels je je je tiens tout
un tas de de de dispositifs sur
l'intégration la le meilleur
apprentissage du français et et tout ça
me semble aller dans le bon sens et et
être plutôt justement très cohérent
initialement qu'est-ce qu'avait dit
Monsieur reetaillot qu'est-ce qu'avait
dit la droite en montrant ses gros ses
gros bras
non pas de régularisation de toute façon
un droit opposable pas de régularisation
un droit opposable à partir du moment où
un dispositif et dans un texte de loi
par définition il est opposable donc
arrêtons avec ce mot opposable ou pas
opposable c'est c'est c'est notre règle
c'est-à-dire que quand il y a quelque
chose que qui a été inscrit dans la dans
la loi on peut l'opposer par voilà c'est
c'est c'est assez logique donc on avait
un premier temps pas de régularisation
pas de régularisation pas de
régularisation on voit bien parce que
les sénateurs du Sénat enfin les
sénateurs républicains côtoient les gens
sur les territoires aussi on voit bien
qu'il y a un besoin il y a un besoin
économique et il y a un besoin de
répondre à des situations de personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui injustes et on le
sait bien les mêmes qui parfois montent
les gros bras sont ceux qui font des
dossiers avec le préfet ou appelle le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour régulariser
une situation donc arrêtons l'hypocrisie
avec le préfet oui mais le préfet le
préfet aujourd'hui le préfet aujourd'hui
gardera la possibilité de dire non quand
il y a des situations c'est pas un droit
de vetto c'est plutôt un droit
d'appréciation et de dire attendez là
j'ai des éléments objectifs qui me
disent que ce n'est pas juste et ce
n'est
pas que que qu'il y a un trouble à
l'ordre public il y a quelque chose qui
qui fonctionne pas mais que l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat les parlementaires
décident des critères permettant cette
régularisation ça me semble être le
minimum pour un état de droit on ne fait
pas de santé en gérant l'urgence la
santé c'est de la prévention c'est du
travail d'accompagnement c'est du long
terme et quand on est dans l'urgence
c'est trop tard et ça coûte beaucoup
plus cher on a auditionné un certain
nombre d'acteurs de la santé du
directeur d'hôpital à l'aide soignante
tous nous ont dit et surtout dans les
zones un peu compliquées genre s sa par
exemple tous nous ont dit mais si vous
faites ça aide médicale d'urgence ils
étaient on éétait même pas au niveau
Suppr on supprime tout vous allez causer
des troubles dans les hôpitaux un coup
faramineux et un problème de santé
publique pour tout le monde pour tous
nos concitoyens donc gardons l'aide
médicale d'État on en fait un fantasme
certains en font un bâton rouge je peux
vous assurer que ça fait faire des
économies à la santé en France j'aime
bien cet aveu madame Jourda vous avez
voulu faire de tour vous non mais vous
allez vous avez vous avez voulu faire de
la politique et vous avez voulu
stigmatiser
un certain nombre de de personnes et et
et un dispositif en en le critiquant
mais en réalité en voyant bien qu'il est
efficace et qui fonctionne et en en
changeant le nom vous vous êtes vraiment
pris les pieds dans le tapis pour le
coup bon voilà en réalité c'est bien la
preuve que quand on fait des des qu'on
est sur les sujets de politique
migratoire moi je le dis toujours il
faut mettre le plus loin possible les
idéologies et essayer de travailler dans
l'efficacité le pragmatisme et le
respect de nos valeurs républicaines
c'est beaucoup plus simple de faire un
rapport par un rapport gouvernemental où
on a accès à tous les chiffres et
peut-être que Monsieur stéphanini s'est
rendu compte de son erreur après moi je
moi je vois dans le rapport il dit qu'il
faut aller plus loin en réalité le
rapport il dit qu'il faut éviter les
ruptures de soins il faut la transition
entre le le la personne qui est
irrégulière et qui devienne régulière
c'est un vrai sujet parce que là-dessus
on est moi je suis assez d'accord il
faut qu'on revoit enfin voilà c'est un
beau travail de de d'analyse qui nous
permettre d'avoir un débat serein un
dernier mot de conclusion est-ce que un
accord vous sent possible sur ce texte
est-ce que la majorité présidentielle
tend encore la main au LR et espère le
vote de LR à Ran balanon bah depuis le
début de de cette mandature on a fait on
a trouvé beaucoup d'accords et donc je
je pense que peut-être vous allez
souvent sur la ligne du Sénat de droite
oui non je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord sur sur
certains textes on a su imposer voilà
j'étais j'étais j'étais dans la
commission mixte paritaire du texte
strrain par exemple je pense qu'on a
fait un bon travail avec les les
sénateurs et on a réussi à aboutir bon
est-ce qu'on aboutira c'est pas un drame
si on aboutit pas moi je le dis c'est
aussi le travail parlementaire on
l'oublie c'est des navettes he avec un
dernier mot c'est le mot à l'Assemblée
nationale